my name is Susan scarve all I am a
bookseller here at politics and prose on
behalf of Karla Cohen and Barbara Meade
and all the other booksellers here thank
you and welcome to politics and
Burroughs this evening we are very
pleased to welcome dr. Vali Nasr who is
here to discuss his new book this year
revival to most Western eyes all Islamic
movements look alike surprisingly
there's been little written about the
bitter divide between Shia and Sunni yet
without understanding their ancient
conflict and it's modern embodiment it's
impossible to comprehend current events
in the Middle East
professor Nasser is the leading expert
on Islam who specializes in political
and social developments in the Muslim
world he is a professor of Middle East
and Southeast Asia politics and
associate chair of research at the
department of national security affairs
at the Naval Postgraduate School he is
written several books and articles
including the recently published
democracy in Iran on behalf of everyone
at politics and proofs please help me
welcome dr. Bali Nasser
good evening thank you for that
introduction it's very good to be here
and to talk about this topic it seems
like everywhere we turn these days there
is discussion of the Shia and Sunni
conflict and the importance of this year
to the region since 2003 this has become
much important to public discussion in
Iraq we saw increasingly the importance
of the Shia first as a new force that we
encountered as we try to sort out the
different political factions in Iraq and
then gradually we saw that the entire
enterprise in Iraq became mired in
sectarian conflict most notably since
February 2006 when there was a
destruction of a major Shia shrine and
now there's upwards of a hundred people
a day killed in sectarian violence which
threatens the unity and stability of
Iraq more recently we have seen an
upsurge of conflict in Lebanon which
involves the Hezbollah which we were for
a long time had been a player in the
arab-israeli conflict but this time with
a much more distinctly sectarian tone to
it not only because Iran which is the
most important Shia country in the
region is supporting Hezbollah but also
because the other sect in the region
namely the Sunnis in the form of
governments in Saudi Arabia Jordan Egypt
and also in the form of radical clerics
in the Arab world very quickly
identified what was happening as a Shia
push for power and try to limit its
popularity by playing the sectarian card
and then there is the issue of Iran
which has been with us for a while and
the u.s. attempt to deal with the rising
Iranian power and influence in the
region with the importance of Iran's
nuclear program
has been ongoing and there have been and
it has been a part of discussions about
Iraq and other issues but more recently
there is a recognition that Iran is
connected to many other important issues
in the region because of these ties that
bind it ties of sec ties of identity
that bind it with other communities in
the region so as we take stock of things
the most important conflicts that we are
dealing with right now the one with Iran
the one in Iraq and the one in Lebanon
they are about different things but
there is one trend that runs through
them and that is this factor of a
resurgent Shia identity and assertion of
power and certainly resistance to it and
my belief is that in many ways this is a
very important new cleavage in Middle
East politics that in some ways has or
had always been there but it was just
below the surface it was a fault line
that was just below the surface but in
since the Iraq war it has come to the
fore and since it's come to the fore it
is important to all the other conflicts
and it is impacting them and that we are
dealing essentially with a new region
whose makeup is different and that every
other issue that we have to deal with
the arab-israeli issue issues of oil
issues of security have to be looked at
in that context I think the RV's
relation is very instructive is probably
the oldest most prominent conflict in
the region but this time around it has a
very clear sectarian tone and this is
completely new to this conflict now this
is this is complex in some ways because
it is one of those issues that it is
both old and new
it's a sectarian division which much
like in Christianity when we think about
the division between the Eastern Church
and Western Church or between Protestant
and Catholicism it seems to have some
archaic roots at some point in history
it's about theology it's about faith it
brings out if you would all historical
memories and the way in which people
relate to truth in their everyday
lives to their values and alike and it's
in some ways it is ancient the Shiites
and Sunnis parted away from one another
right at the beginning of Islam so in
some ways each sees itself as the
original orthodoxy much like the
difference between the Orthodox and the
Catholics and the dispute was seemingly
very political at the beginning namely
it was over who would succeed prophet
muhammad and whereas the sunnis decided
that the community would choose who
would be the best successor who would be
the most eligible to succeed him in
terms of qualities the shared believed
that there was a spiritual essence to
the prophet that would pass through his
progeny to modern times in some ways
this years would very well understand
the plot to The Da Vinci Code the
importance of bloodline and they
believed that the the veritable leaders
of the community were the descendants of
the Prophet well they lost that battle
very quickly namely the dominant form of
government and religious authority in
Islam fell under the Caliphate at the
time and the Shiites dissented and the
faith consolidated particularly when the
grandson of the Prophet the third Shia
amount was buried in Karbala was was not
died a horrific death standing up to a
far larger Syrian army that was sent to
subdue his claim to Authority and that
event
much like the crucifixion of Christ was
a formative event for Shiites and to
this day they commemorate that event on
a festival of Ashura and that Sciences
burial place in Iraq is the most
passionately loved location for Shiites
and theme of martyrdom suffering the
standing up of the underdog before a far
more powerful force have become
important themes in Shiite life and what
most separates Shiites from Sonny's is
not the minor ways in which they
practice the faith
friendly but it is that the passion and
drama that is associated with the the
Saints that Shiites hold holy and the
places of their burial which they visit
and all the ceremonies that are
associated with it these are issues of
faith that have no reflection in
Scripture in Islam but are very near and
dear to share as there's an immediate
personal direct passionate relationship
the between Shiites and their faith and
this generation of science has a
reflection for instance in Catholicism
in Catholics looking at Shiites visiting
najaf and karbala could see similarities
with the visitation of the shrine of
Fatima in Portugal or Virgin of
Guadalupe in Mexico or the very fact
that the Shiites believe that Saints
have Grace and their burial places have
Grace and these are places you visit and
pray and ask for forgiveness and the
like those don't have reflection in
Sunni Islam which is in some ways more
Protestant this approach to faith
it'sit's about the individuals direct
relationship with God and the scripture
and you you you look at texts more
literally rather than try to read
meaning into it and there is no
intermediary between man and God now the
shirts and Sunnis have fought about
these principles over time and some and
in many occasions they have also lived
in coexistence and right and peacefully
in many parts of the world but the
modern period has been particularly
difficult and particularly the past five
decades in the Arab world for the
Shiites has been particularly difficult
namely although they have lived as a
majority and have ruled over Iran in the
Arab world regardless of whether they
were a majority or a minority they were
suppressed they didn't have a seat at
the table they were not part of the
political community part of the family
of the nation they were always accused
of being Iranian or having
being loyal to Iran even most recently
the president of Egypt said that Arab
Shiites are almost always which is that
means always almost always are more
loyal to Iran than to their own
countries and this myth of being
beholden to Iran is obviously repeated
with the notion that Hezbollah even
though it is very aggressively supported
by Iran but it that it is completely
controlled by Iran
well Iraq changed that in many many
regards and in important regards one is
that Iraq essentially by removing what
was probably the most oppressive Sunni
regime from power and then essentially
allowing politics to flow in the
direction that the numbers would permit
allowed the shares to assume power in
others they showed up to vote there are
I told us told them democracy is a good
thing because you have the weight of
numbers on your side
in fact the shirts everywhere have the
weight of numbers even where they're a
minority still they'll get more than
what they have today if they voted for
instance in Saudi Arabia in the Eastern
Province when there was recently
elections this is a Shia province the
Shiites participated by the ratio of two
to one
- Sunnis and is the very first time in
their history that they actually are
sitting on City Council's and one Shia
local Shia engineer said we vote to say
we exist and when this transition of
power became from the Sunnis in Iraq who
the Shiites became confirmed by
government that took over on their prime
minister Jeffrey who was predominantly
Shia this was very symbolic this was the
very first time that there was an Arab
Shia state it has never existed in
history before back to the beginning of
Islam there has not been a real Shia
political entity and the psychological
blow of this - Sunnis who have used over
time they believe that they have they
represent Islam they represent this
political authority they represent this
religious authority was very significant
and the fact that the u.s. obviously was
the facilitator here did not endear the
u.s. to Sunni insurgents in Iraq who
faulted the US for doing this
in fact he al-qaeda terrorist Abu Musab
Zarqawi would always pair the u.s. and
the Shiites in his condemnation has
between enemies one within one without
but whose enterprises were you know sort
of reinforcing but the problem in Iraq
was that it wouldn't stay there namely
what happened in Iraq has been important
everywhere else because Shiites
everywhere in the Arab world saw the
possibility of something better saw the
possibility that political change can
actually pass power into their hands and
it became far more expectant of change
and this if you would began a kind of
fervor in the in the region that was
disturbing and to be the first element
of Shia revival is really this this
political momentum among the Shiites in
the region they're not led by the same
ruler there is no more a single
Ayatollah Khomeini who's leading them
there is no single movement the issue is
that everywhere in the in the Arab world
the shares have the same problem
therefore the responses are the same and
so it's oh it's a movement of many
different communities all expecting
political change to give them power but
Iraq also facilitated other things it
just opened the borders for pilgrims
from Lebanon from Iran but particularly
from Iran as far away as Pakistan and
India to go visit the shrine cities
there was sort of new networks of people
business trade that began to be forged
and at the center of this was this most
senior Ayatollah in Iraq
I told a Sistani who we always think of
him in the context of Iraq but his
importance beyond Iraq has become quite
noted in other words larger and larger
numbers of Shiites in Iraq outside of
Iraq have begun to adopt him as the ayah
so that they would follow and give him
them their their donations their
religious taxes and religious donations
and and in him if you would you have the
element of a of a of a web that is
responsible for a cultural revival among
this year's he's not alone but you know
but this whole sort of network of
clerics from Lebanon to to South Asia to
Pakistan and India is now very critical
in bolstering this surgeon identity
among the Shiites now in many in many
ways this this was a this was a serious
challenge to US policy because when the
u.s. went into Iraq its expectation was
not that it had to deal with mutually
exclusive political aspirations of two
sexes they thought democracy was about
individual rights they thought of Iraqis
as Iraqis with the exception of Kurds
which we we knew did not view themselves
as Iraqis but we never really thought
that the Iraqi society may come apart in
this particular manner and that this
would open very different attitudes
towards US presence and policy in the
region between the two population groups
in the region and and in many ways we'll
notice we were not ready for it and
perhaps that they are absence of
readiness on our part allowed Iraq which
was the very first place we had a
transition of power to also become the
most bloody example in others this was
not a good beginning to be a long
process of gradual transfer of power
from Sunnis to Shiites and I think in
many ways it did have it have a shocking
it was a shock to the Shiites as well
and that the the ferocity of resistance
to shear assumption of power was quite a
wake-up call I mean now we look at Iraq
and we see that both communities are
killing one another but for the first
three years it wasn't that way
it was mostly attacks by insurgents
on Shiites whether they were policemen
or new recruits to the army or they were
average citizens and the like and and
the culmination was the destruction of
one of the major Shia shrines in Samara
north of Baghdad and I think that was a
breaking point for Shias they decided
that you know that restraint is
interpreted as cowardice and they
decided to establish a balance of terror
in Iraq and and things then began to go
down a spiral and and we haven't been
able to restore a situation of stability
commensurate to what was before not that
before was good but it was not it was
not in a sort of a free-for-all one
response I think that the shears began
to contemplate was that whenever the
Shiites have risen in power is in modern
times you've had you've seen Sunni
sectarianism of trying to do to corner
them marginalize them by calling him
heretics questioning their their Arab
identity or question in their faith and
the sheer response is always being to
look for those causes that can bring
everybody together rather than pulling
apart and there is no cause better than
that and none the cause of of focusing
attention on Israel and I think it is
not at least one dimension of Iran and
his Bullas attempt to hijack the
Palestinian cause is that it first of
all focuses attention away from
sectarianism the rise of Iranian power
the rise of Shia power in the region and
focuses it on the common enemy and it
seems to have work because in the very
first few days radical clerics did their
best to raise the sectarian issue raise
the image of Iraq to convince the rest
of the Arab world not to support
Hezbollah but for now it didn't work
secondly I think the Shiites
believe that by showing a strong face on
the arab-israeli issue they will earn
the badge the legitimacy of off of power
and I think you know the more probably
the most important symbolism coming out
of the current Lebanon War is that
Hezbollah has defended its little
village on the border far better than
Saddam defended that the seat of the
great Abbasid power and in a culture
that has accomplishment deficit and in
which in which sort of a muscular
defence of rights and honor matters it
is it serves as a as legitimating the
sheer claim that they have a right to
right to power and but by the same token
the Lebanon War has also elevated
sectarianism beyond Iraq mainly because
of the reaction that Hezbollah received
from official Arab governments and also
from radical clerics that they
highlighted the fact that this that
Hezbollah Iranian Alliance is a Shia
Alliance and that and try to question
the legitimacy of the Shia to speak for
Arabs and and by so doing it has
essentially made sectarianism a regional
issue in other words the Shia Crescent
about which King Abdullah of Jordan
warned early in 2003-2004 now seems to
have become a reality but the problem is
that whereas in 2003 there was an
opportunity to probably harness the
rising shear force in the region in some
manner in favor of the u.s. that moment
is rapidly passing and the more sort of
anti-american voices among the Shia or
are coming to the fore and they that
will cause instability one hates to be a
prophet of doom but I'm not terribly
optimistic that we've seen the worst of
in conflict yet pass or that it's full
impact on the shape of the region has
yet known first of all the the
settlement of power distribution in Iraq
is by no means done yet there had the
big battle about who gets what in Iraq
is yet to be fought out and it's not
going to be around the constitutional
table it's going to be in the street and
in some ways the battle for Baghdad has
already begun and that will likely write
its own rules for Middle East politics
but I also think once the lebanon war is
is settled you knows once there is a
cease-fire the the the whole issue of
the the shia a bid for control of the
palestinian issue and the sunni response
to it within Lebanon and within the
region will actually come to the fore
because in many ways the Iranian
Hezbollah axis has been largely
political in what he wanted to achieve
and that is not going to go from without
a response come back from from the other
side in in the coming time period so for
the u.s. the challenge I think in many
ways and I hope my book would contribute
to that is to understand what are the
what are the the issues that are stake
what is the historical backdrop what is
it that defines these face and what is
the historical legacy that that each
sect carries in terms of its memory of
the other in terms of what it what it
believes it deserves and what the other
one should get and I I don't think we
can think clearly about the Middle East
or formulate policy clearly about it
without without having a a strong
understanding of what does the sectarian
dynamic in the Middle East today mean
and where is it going to take the Middle
East in the future when I stop here and
see if there any questions
hi let's see I've heard people talking
about sectarian violence in Iraq that it
might turn into a civil war and some
people say that it's already started and
the dangers of that spreading so could
you comment on the possibility of it
spreading and what it might look like
and how much of a problem it could be
well there are many scenarios that can
happen we often associate civil wars
with very clear boundary lines with two
sides having organized regular forces
but civil wars were better put actually
civil conflicts can take many forms in
India for instance at the time when
India and Pakistan separated in 1947
there were no militias there was no
battle line there was merely killing in
every community of Hindus and Muslims
and at the end of the day some 2 million
people died and two countries were born
out of it and many more close to 10
million people lost their homes or were
displaced so we may end up if you would
in a in a conflict that is just going to
bleed Iraq until there is a de-facto
division or you may actually have a far
larger eruption where you go from a
hundred people dead per day to a far
larger numbers and actually the militias
may begin to engage much more much more
directly
is that the absence of what were
accustomed to in the Western world
insofar as democracy is concerned that
the Shia and the Sunni do not see
resolving their differences in a
so-called democratic process they don't
have any history of following that
procedure well it's not only absence of
history this absence of constitutional
mechanisms
you know democracy is about rule of law
it's about power sharing and then it's
about elections and often we sort of
reverse that order but you know whenever
you have democratization the democracy
let me put it this way democracy in the
long run brings stability but
democratization or young democracies are
inherently actually unstable because the
very first thing that an opening of a
system does is actually to create
winners and losers and the question is
well how do you accommodate or bring in
the losers or whether or not they're
willing to accept their loss and in Iraq
I think early on the Sun needs through
the insurgency believed there was an
option other than power sharing they
could actually get it back if they push
the u.s. quickly enough and they hit the
Shia's hard enough you could have a
Sunni restoration in in Baghdad and part
of the reason why the Shiites engaged in
a counter-terror as of February 2006 is
exactly to convince the other side that
that's not going to happen
but we are expectation that you know a
country in which there has not been no
practice of democracy that has been
based on specific suppression of a
majority Kurdish entire population by a
minority people are just going to shake
hands and say you know from tomorrow we
each will take what we want and are not
going to put up a resistance is absurd
even in the u.s. you know when for
instance civil right laws were passed in
the south there was resistance to it and
the resistance was because it was racial
but also because it meant something
about distribution of power
minority that was used to getting most
of the power would now have to share it
at the ballot box and therefore there
was resistance positive role that the
Kurds can play in this well I think the
Kurds are pretty much out of Iraq and
the only reason that they would they
were they would abide by an Iraqi state
is because an outright independence can
get can cause trouble with Iran and
Turkey but there are key areas that are
important there is a constitutional
renegotiation that is supposed to happen
in the next few months and if it's not
successful that will be the beginning of
of civil war and then there is the
status of Kirkuk which is a city that
the Kurds wanted back because Saddam
relocated a lot of Arabs particularly
Shiites to Kirkuk they want to take the
city back the Arabs don't want to leave
so unless the Kurds are willing to
negotiate over Kirkuk or negotiate over
the constitution they could contribute
to aggravating the problem you mentioned
that we may not have seen the worst of
the sectarian violence are we heading
toward a regional Shia Sunni war ignited
first by the war in Iraq then spreading
to Lebanon where the Shia are 45% of the
population and then the rest of the
region when we couldn't have a series of
cascading conflicts you know there was a
Lebanon I think may very well be in for
a for a bout of sectarian conflict
because his bullets coming out of this
conflict very strong it's going to lay
claim to Lebanon the entire issue of who
speaks for Lebanon who had a right to
declare war these are all issues that
are going to be put forward and Iran may
very light as I said might might become
much more violent and if Iraq in
particular becomes a civil war without a
doubt he will suck in the other regional
countries around it Iran on the parts of
the Shia's in one form or another Saudi
Arabia and Jordan and
Egypt and the like on the side of the
Sunnis I would say it's like it's the
iran-iraq war moved 200 kilometers west
and rethought again in the in the the
first decade of the 21st century but I
don't think if in terms of it you know
sustained long regional war I it's a
question of you know it's question of
what is the relative power of each side
and obviously I think militarily Iran is
probably the the heavyweight in the
region in others without us getting
involved I don't see the other armies in
the region being capable of you know
having a region-wide war against
particularly Iran Syria and Hezbollah
configuration but I think more likely is
that you're going to have a series of
conflicts much like the one now it's a
moral skillet which were connected
together and there will be the same
players in each of them on a particular
site what can the United States do if
anything in helping it prevent stop
being a regional conflict well I think
the first order of business is to is to
try to bring the existing conflicts to a
halt particularly the one in Lebanon as
soon as possible and to try to bring
certain degree of stability to the
region the Middle East has become
increasingly volatile for re4 varieties
of reasons there is insecurity among
various population groups the Sunnis
because of Iraq or what Iraq might mean
for them now the Lebanon War there you
have ongoing radicalization of the
politics in the region as a consequence
of these conflicts
you know Brit a breath of sort of
stopping conflict I think is the most
important thing I think the one lesson
we can learn out of Lebanon is that
military conflicts not going to solve
the problem is not going to change the
political situation is actually rather
going to aggravate it and we need to
sort of back away from allowing
conflicts to go on in the hope that they
would bring about a solution that we
would like
to what extent do you feel that the
self-proclaimed
decision-makers of the US government are
aware of the ramifications that you have
so aptly described I have that I have no
way of knowing that all I can do is to
sort of put the ideas and the arguments
out there hoping hoping that people will
read them thanks for an excellent
presentation it seems like a key to a
lot of solving a lot of this problem
would be to is through Iran do you think
that we should talk to Iran just simply
talk without preconditions I mean you
think it would be useful I know
President Edina God sent president bush
a letter a couple weeks ago and you know
the president just dismissed it which
clearly there was light in that letter
that you know I'm sure there probably
wasn't much he could respond to you but
he could certainly could have used it as
an opening to at least begin a dialogue
and secondly along with that question if
you do think we should talk to talk to
Iran and engaging in them in some sort
of diplomacy I was reading how in
Iranian culture there's this very strong
tendency to sort of you know not say
what you mean and give misdirection and
speech and I guess all cultures are
prone to that a little bit but I guess
in Iran it's a very strong cultural
tendency so how would we if we do decide
to engage them how would we overcome
that do we have the capability to if we
wanted to engage them do we have the
capability to do it effectively well I'm
the last part your comment first I think
you know diplomacy always involves a
cultural challenge I mean we had similar
kinds of difficulties you know what is
it that the Chinese want yeah I think
Henry Kissinger wants that we play chess
they they play a sort of sort of a
frontal and there's a Chinese game that
he referred to there the mentality about
what is winning and losing is very
different from ours but that's always a
challenge you know to understand you
know what are the red lines and bottom
lines and you know expectations of the
other side I think there's enough you
know Iranian experts in this country and
Iranian expatriates that can
that you know for the US government to
draw on that we can safely say that you
know Iran is not a sort of a deep hole
that that we can't understand Iran is a
easy challenge because it is a
dictatorship it is it's got a president
right now there is a hardliner that is
militant whose rhetoric does not serve
his country or the situation in the
region any favors and there is a certain
amount of danger in in any authoritarian
government that feels overconfident that
feels that is honor that feels itself to
be a power on the rise I think Iran sort
of has sometimes it's reminiscent of
Japan of 1930s but and and and therefore
we talking to Iran does not mean
recognizing Iran it does not mean that
you know we sideline those issues that
that you know morally and and and
politically we have difficulty with such
as you know support for democratic
rights in Iran or Human Rights or or
insisting on Iran suspended support for
terrorism and the like I mean those are
issues that the US should still push but
it's import but we are also at a point
where we assume that we could manage
Iran with a varieties of tools but no
need for diplomacy that that was the one
two that we really didn't need and well
that's the risk because even during the
Soviet period we always use diplomatic
tools in fact you use diplomacy with
your enemies now with your friends I
mean you know just should not need
diplomacy with your friends you can
always the point political appointees as
ambassadors is not an issue to to to
deal with but but we somehow decided
that actually we don't need any
diplomacy with our enemies now the
problem is the current strategy is not
hitting its mark with Iran I mean
they're we're not able to threaten them
to submission we're not able to give
carrots through submission to get them
to submit to the will of the
international community and you know
military option I think probably looks
less a try
without after Lebanon than it did before
Lebanon because ultimately the lesson of
Lebanon is you know that you know
overwhelming military power may very
well not be able to get the job done and
then end of the day the one you're
attacking actually becomes politically
far more popular than than it was before
you before you attack them and I think
also it's the very first time in the
region where we find ourselves sort of
without with one hand tied behind our
back because whenever we had problems
with the Palestinian issue other issues
we always relied on allies in the region
to do what it needs to be done so you
know we can always get Israelis to
compromise and an issue or talk to them
and then it was the job of the Saudis
and the Egyptians and the Jordanians to
invite our effort to Sharm al-sheikh and
give him a pep talk and get him to you
know do something but this time for the
first time there is nobody on the other
side who among our allies we can talk to
his bola so there's no way for us to
really play that role without at some
level having some kind of contact with
Syria and Iran and III again reiterate I
think talking to Iran it does not mean
that we're sort of throwing in the towel
and we're accepting the Iranian regime
and everything it wants to the contrary
I think it's a matter of sort of trying
to figure how we can how can we maneuver
Iran to where we want through means
other than the ones that are actually
not currently working none of these
states in the Middle East are really
legitimate States their sovereign but
when all those barns were created by two
men one in particular which is in
Churchill now Winston Churchill to
Zionist walls is God he got its clowns
down the road here I think there are
going to be words in Churchill what is
happening is the collapse of the British
Empire
finally and Americans have finally do
the job Corie emergence re-emergence of
new successor states Israel Iran where
the Turks wake up maybe Turkey to
carving up the [ __ ] heartland
hope so I'm sure so I go go go go for it
however one of the things they have to I
like to know is that this clowns this
trio of Chaney bushland what's that
guy's name : : bowel did a double cross
in the shares in 91 and that burnt that
really burnt to here it was rise up and
we'll support you instead
arms and fuel was supplied to survivor
said by hair in general and the she has
a wiped out and there was enormous
burning right to share community about
this what happened how could they do the
same mistake twice three times well the
memory of that uprising is very
important in Iraq and I mean essentially
when the Shias rose up and expecting
that the US would support them and then
our regional allies Saudi Arabia and
Jordan prevailed upon the u.s. saying
that you know a Shia Iraq would be
pro-iranian shouldn't support that
uprising the uprising collapsed there
are various estimates of how many
Shiites were killed upwards of a hundred
thousand escaped to Iran but you know
estimates are as high as 300,000 she has
were killed and you know those are the
mass graves of southern Iraq that have
been discovered since the fall of Saddam
in fact Saddam's regime after that
became far more sectarian because it was
very clear that you know Sunni rule had
to suppress an awakened Shia population
the reason it's important is because you
have the same kind of issue going I mean
when Arab governments begin to sort of
publicly call on Washington to abandon
the Shia in Iraq when they say things
like you know the shares are going to be
pro Iranian and Iran is a is a pariah
state your enemy why you supporting them
or when you know President Mubarak says
you know the shares are always loyal to
Iran to Iraqi Shias that creates
nervousness there is a there is a memory
of when this the same cabal influenced
Washington to abandon abandon me Shia an
inch in in Iraq they talk of it as a
second betrayal and in fact particularly
when
the US ambassador in Iraq decided to
bring the Sunnis into the police by
beginning to prep put pressure on the
shears and began to flirt with Sunni
leaders there was a immediate warning in
Iraq that that you know the same events
of 1991 are repeating and the one reason
that the shears won't give up on their
militias is because they don't trust the
US they don't trust that you know
ultimately end of the day there will not
be another deal that would put them in a
cage I think one of the important issues
and you know this is obviously the
problem with with with it with the fact
that Iran has been a theocracy and an
anti-american state and is a pariah
state but the the kind of influence that
Sunnis have in Washington is not matched
by the Shias yeah the United States
hasn't talked to a Shia leader the past
29 years and you know even Nouri
al-maliki or Ibrahim Jaffrey simply
don't have the same kind of access that
King Abdullah and King Abdullah and
whose President Mubarak have I think you
know in Palmer's book there is a very
telling line where he's reporting to the
president about the shears in Iraq and
the president says they tell me they're
all liars and who told the president
they're all liars who has that kind of
access to educate the President on what
he ought to think about the Shias and
and that kind of access the shares don't
have and because they don't have it
there is a great deal of anxiety about
about what the ultimate u.s. intentions
might be um thank you the last month or
so I started looking at some of the
different plans there's a 28 point plan
that they were discussing in Cairo and a
twenty-one point plan about resolving
the issue and right now people from code
pink went over to Jordan to discuss with
some of the Iraqi people based on the
Cairo and there were some disagreements
so I I solicited some discussion from
people in the field of conflict experts
in the field of conflict resolution
internationally and actually we wrote up
some underlying principles that would
underlie any plan like for what for
example the
as long as there's an occupation it's
gonna split everybody into and they
can't even think you know there's no way
they can resolve the problems at the
parties themselves have to resolve their
problems that all the parties have to
come to the table even the extreme ones
you know like now you'd bring Hamas and
Hezbollah and by excluding them you make
them more violent and meeting expert so
anyway I'm just curious if you're
familiar with the plan and if anybody is
using any people with expertise in the
body of knowledge on conflict studies
I'm not familiar with the specifics of
the plans but I think all of these plans
have a problem is that the the bigger
forces in the region which is for
instance in this case Iran they're their
vested interests don't often coincide
with it with what is in these clans in
other words because they what's the
exactly exactly because they're not
sitting at the table so they're not you
don't have their buy-in into whatever
you're going to agree to and they don't
believe that their positions are
represented or protected and they have a
vested interest in fact in in
undermining it I don't think any of
these it's not just a matter of in my
opinion of only bringing the parties
within together you have to acknowledge
that these parties have regional
sponsors that we like it or not that's
that's a fact and there are good ones
that are bad ones some of them have
relations with the u.s. some are u.s.
enemies but this is the reality and I
think the model that actually worked is
the model of the of the Bonn conference
and Afghanistan where when the Taliban
fail government fell there was a
conference that was held in Bonn and all
the regional actors came including Iran
and there was intense negotiations
between ambassador Khalilzad
I was now in Iraq and the Iranian
ambassador at the United Nations
although neither side wanted to
advertise that these contacts occurred
and the the consequence of that was that
Afghanistan had a rapid transition to
the Karzai government at the beginning
and got a constitution and relatively
quick order because everybody at that
time understood that doesn't matter how
many warlords you bring if the
Pakistanis and the Iranians are not
there if they're you and the whose backs
are not there it doesn't matter what
these groups agree to it's not going to
hold unless you have those forces at the
table as well could everyone just please
keep their questions very short question
thanks I have a simple question what do
you think it's gonna take for the people
living in Muslim countries to move into
the modern world by adopting more of a
live and live live and let live and let
live attitude of give up victimhood give
up jihad give up honor killings give up
sectarian violence stop scapegoating
Israel and I mean what do you what he
proposed as a scheme could you could you
comment on that I mean I I see trying to
get honest honest leaders and moderating
the religion and trying to get something
the equivalent of a Radio Free Europe
when it's that what you're saying is a
tall order but I mean none of these are
going to happen very quickly and
elsewhere it hasn't happened it requires
a process that that begins to reduce
conflict in the region and also
gradually begins to open the political
systems in the region on maladies in the
political process in the Middle East and
nothing's going to move forward until
those those maladies are address it's
the same thing could have been said
about Northern Ireland which was a for
about the Basque region in in Spain
where seemingly it was engaged in a kind
of political behavior that didn't fit
Europe and there was enormous amount of
hatred between communities and
and ultimately the understanding was
that you have to have a process that
that engages and tries to deal with the
core issue in those societies and I
think there's no simple answer here but
but you know the beginning would be to
to deal with it with what are the
sources or maladies in the region two
things what a connection between the the
Iranian u.s. conflict over over the
Iran's an atomic project and the insight
and this and the Hezbollah and Hamas
starting their their conflicts with
Israel I when we we don't know for sure
whether or not what kind of a role the
Iran had in in starting this conflict
many Iranian leaders claimed that the
conflict really began a year ago when
Prime Minister Hariri was assassinated
and once the u.s. began to push Syria
out of Lebanon they assumed that it that
it there would be a war so it's a matter
of when actually would start but there
is no doubt that whether or not Iran was
directly involved it has in many ways
benefited one is that yes the United
Nation is now bogged down in too much in
Lebanon to address Iran's resolution
secondly Iran has underscored something
that it always wanted that it asked you
have that the u.s. recognizes that it is
it matters that it holds the cards not
only in Iraq but in Afghanistan in
Lebanon and the like and that you can't
have peace and stability without Iran
they wanted to underscore this Iranian
leaders have been saying these kinds of
things that you know the u.s. doesn't
understand you know how important Iran
is and they've achieved that and also
they've had other benefits in this war
one is that they be they've seen in this
for a sort of degrading of
of the power of military solutions
secondly is that they've even at the low
level they began to showcase and test
new weapon systems that are proven quite
surprising anti-tank missiles you know
rockets unmanned drones and alike and
all of these are designed to make
signals to the West about you know what
might expect if you were to attack your
own so in many ways it's it's helped
them and then they look at the growing
anti-americanism on the street in the
Arab world they look at the weakening of
Saudi Arabia Jordan and Egypt as a
consequence of this war and they see his
bolus popularity and then they make a
calculation that their hand is a lot
stronger now so they don't need to
compromise so whether they intended it
or not they they are the beneficiary and
then it makes dealing with them a lot
more difficult
thank you very much Anson considering
like the history of the United States in
the Middle East and and sort of we've
always done a lot of stuff in other
people's names but for our own benefit
what role what role should the United
States play at this point in other words
should we start backing out should we
take a leadership role in in other words
are we messing things more up we being
there what should we do well I I think
in many ways we're stuck between a stone
and a hard place and leaving the Middle
East is not an option even even leaving
Iraq and in some ways is not an option
even if we end up having to do it for
domestic pressure it's not a good
solution mainly because we cannot leave
a territory like Iraq to its own devices
without a government and a military that
can establish law and order we learned
in Afghanistan that you cannot have a
free zone particularly one which already
is infested with you know the worst
kinds of terrorism and militancy and
secondly you know if Iraq falls apart in
a major way it will impact the entire
rim of the Persian Gulf and you know we
have energy interests we have security
interests and the like so in some ways
the decision just to leave particularly
Iraq is not a simple one I think the
only major difference is that we have
thought for a while now that there is a
sort of a razor sharp knife of military
option that can sort of cut cut through
you know the Gordian knot of the
problems in the region and solve them
and we learn now that that's not that
easy that that knife has become
increasingly blunt and it actually
causes other problems so that's what
that's why suggestion that you know we
need to think of other mechanisms to
address what our interests are in other
words we still sure we still have a
problem with Iran because it's a
dictatorial regime that is that is that
has negative influence on in many
regards on the region supports terrorism
and the like it's a big problem if it
were
to acquire nuclear weapons so I mean
that's still a problem the question is
not that we should forget those problems
the question is we have to find a
different way of tackling them tackling
them that would be more productive could
you elaborate on your analogy of Iran to
Japan in the 30s that's a fairly dire
kind of outcome it is and I mean history
is replete with examples that I can
think of Prussia I didn't think of also
China in the 1960s and the like but Iran
is a is if you would is a rising power
in the region in other words it is
self-consciously sees itself as a
regional power is the economic
wherewithal it has the military
wherewithal it has the size it has the
population base to assert its position
even if you look economically Iran's
gross domestic output is almost twice
that of Saudi Arabia and is well above
that of Egypt and that's not accounting
for you know industrial production which
you know Saudis don't have much of but
the but at the same time this is not a
sort of a peaceful rise you know there
was domestically Iran is an
authoritarian regime with which is after
seen in turn in the direction of reform
a decade ago is turning again in the
direction of a combination of
ideological militancy and sort of rabid
nationalism and it's increasingly ruled
also by a military class in other words
we think of it when we think of Iran we
think of clerics because that sort of
has become the iconic face of Iran but
Iran is in fact Lord now increasingly
run by commanders from the Revolutionary
Guards even the Iranian president is a
veteran of the guards they control a lot
of the economy many aspects of security
and politics and so you have a military
class in Iran that is nationalistic is
highly ideological and it's seized you
know it's Iran on a on a power binge and
wants to assert that power
and you it might not be that Iran will
actually engage in conquests the way to
Japan it this is a different time period
but there is no doubt that Iran wants to
want to leave its mark on the region and
and it's on the conflicts we see the way
it's exerting its influence is is a
consequence of that in part Iran Iran's
problem with the u.s. is that it sees us
as an obstacle to its free reign over
the region thank you for your remarks I
wanted to ask you to focus a little bit
on Syria in a number of different ways
one you have a non Shia government very
much supporting a Shia movement in
Hizballah how does that work out in
terms of Syrian policy the Syria control
Hizbollah or influence Hizbollah more
than Iran does is it about equal what at
what are the what are the different
relations there and also how does
Syria's role with regard to in the past
at least wanting to negotiate with
Israel about the return of the Golan
affect relate to its policy with regards
to supporting Hezbollah and other Shia
groups when the second part of your
question
I mean without a doubt Syria has issues
with Israel there's issues of territory
and his issues of strategic balance
particularly since Syria was pushed out
of Lebanon essentially it lost a lot of
strategic ground to to Israel is far
more militarily vulnerable than when he
was in when it was in Lebanon
and without a doubt I mean the Syrians
very quickly said that you know this is
not about two Israeli soldiers kidnapped
this is about the entire arab-israeli
conflict so they wanted to very quickly
focus the light on on the on the overall
issue as opposed to just a immediate
issue
now the Alois which is the minority
community of about 10% which rules over
Syria is not sheer but it's lineages
through schism in other words the Alois
are an offshoot of shares and the sort
of went on a
tangent and in some ways it's practices
are not Islamic it has I think it
doesn't follow Islamic law it includes
Zoroastrian ancient Iranian practices in
it
but in some ways therefore in the eyes
of the Muslim Brotherhood and the
hardline Sunnis it was even worse than
the Shias it was even further removed on
this years I mean there are old medieval
fatwas by eminent jurists who declare
the the allow is to be heretics and one
of the ways when there was gradually an
Islamic revival in the Middle East the
the Assad regime which is been ruling
Syria which always had a sort of a
secular face and advocated all the Arab
causes turned to a senior Shia cleric in
Lebanon Emma Musa Sadr and then to
Ayatollah Khomeini in Iran both of whom
issued fatwas declaring Alois to be
Shias and therefore to be Muslims so it
is not as you know in other words
whatever connection yeah Louise half to
Islam is through she is not through
Sunnis and but you know the relationship
is tactical I mean Syria was always
Iran's ally during the Arab during the
iran-iraq conflict it was the only Arab
country who supported Iran both of them
have been supporting Hezbollah
I think Iran's relationship to Hezbollah
is far more important than serious Syria
had has a closer tactical relationship
to Hezbollah particularly when he was
the ruler of Lebanon when Iran's
relationship is both far deeper and
culturally and historically and
militarily far far more important I
think Syria always was sort of the place
through which Iran's influence worked
itself into Lebanon and then see really
the micromanagement of the scene in
Lebanon but as we're seeing now I mean
it's really Iran's military financial
support that accounts for his
not not serious thank you very much very
enlightening talk I haven't read your
book but I hope that you have just so
that everybody here gets things in
context I hope you have pointed out that
in fourteen hundred years of history
across the Muslim world barring the
conflicts which invariably are the human
lot not only have the share and the
Sunni lived relatively at peace but the
Christians Jews Hindus and you know X
number of religions have lived in very
much a case of relative peace in that
period and yes but this is just building
up to that because I think we should not
even forget the context that you know
the true biggest conflicts have been in
Europe but within this context what I
want to say is that a lot of the legacy
of what we are seeing today is a very
mixed legacy of colonialism of yes a
certain amount of backwardness of a
period that you know they went through
but we seem to be ignoring also a very
the 800-pound gorilla in the room
because there's Saudi Arabia which
actually has probably been no that's
what I'm asking him but where does he
see the the role of Saudi Arabia in
bringing a more tolerant Middle East
well the points you make are quite quite
apt in other words there is there is
like every religion like every
civilization that's right without every
civilization has periods of of harmony
as well as division and without a doubt
even though as I even written in the
book you know people read their sacred
texts in a context so you know it has to
make meaning to hopes and aspirations
and fears that they have so there is
difference there differences in how
people interpret things over time and we
have to definitely look at you know what
kind of historical baggage what kind of
immediate problems with is it
colonialism is it
economic problems class whatever it is
that accounts for certain things flaring
up
you know his Protestants and Catholics
fought everywhere but it finished why is
it continuing in Northern Ireland you
have to look at that it's not just the
history of you know what Luther said to
Pope that matters there but Saudi Arabia
poses a particular challenge because
well aside from the fact and I think
other other people have said plenty that
its form of practice of certain ISM is
particularly conservative is
particularly intolerant of other
interpretations of Sunnis and let alone
she isn't but its influence in recent
years because of oil money because of
various issues has become far more
prevalent in other words in places where
there was far more tolerance for
instance in India and Pakistan and the
like the Saudi influence has been to
make to sort of distance these
communities and the fact that Saudi
Arabia went into a cold war with Iran
during the Iranian Revolution period
gave it every incentive to promote
anti-shia policies because it believes
shares were likely Iran's Trojan horses
in different places but also there is a
particularly bloody history between
shiahs right where you know in Iraq
Saudi Arabia region and there were Hobby
sector of Saudi Arabia and this is just
you know particular to there namely when
the House of Saud took power on the
Arabian Peninsula as this sort of as the
sword of the Wahhabi
religion and created the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia
there were pogroms of shears and that
legacy is very strong in the minds of
shears and it is very strong in the
minds of Iraqi she has because the Baha
the armies invaded southern Iraq a
number of times and particularly
destroyed the shrine of Hussein in
Karbala so every time there's a bombing
in Iraq the even Ayatollah Sistani
others say well it's not Iraqis who are
doing it it's Wahabis who are doing it
oh it's it's convenient to say well it's
outsiders don't take revenge on your
neighbors but they are also evoking this
memory that look yet again yet again
it's repeating
and particularly with the shrine of
Samara it was for for the shares of Iraq
is very reminiscent of the destruction
of the shrine of Karbala
so yes I mean III think it's very
important for Iran to play a positive
role in the region it's also very
important for Saudi Arabia to do so as
well I think we should focus on both of
them to try to contribute to stability
rather than to compete by and create
instability inexorably is America moves
toward an election they simplified stay
in or get out of Iraq into a
oversimplify question you said we cannot
just get out beyond the military and may
be getting the power and the water back
what strategies and what credibility do
we have to work through Iraq or to
dialogue and with whom or through whom
well I think that it's already shown
that the US has a very difficult time
trying to talk to everybody at once and
you have to create a framework for
compromise and negotiations the u.s.
occupation presence in Iraq is not a
framework it is just a law-and-order
force at best it is not it's not a
framework that that everybody in the
region which would believe that they had
a seat at the table their interests in
Iraq was was served the interests of
their clients were served and can
convince their clients that you know the
compromise and the final deed is a good
one and that's what happened in
Afghanistan you know there was the u.s.
didn't take it upon itself to talk to
every warlord we talked to some but we
talked to their masters and and that
proved to be a far more viable solution
I still think that you know we cannot
impose a compromise on the shares
without the help of their patrons which
is which is Iran and we cannot really
get the Sun needs to accept a final
outcome without without getting the
Saudis and the Jordan is the Egyptian on
board well with the with the Kurds we
are the patron so we can you know sort
of because there's nobody else they day
and they trust the US but but you cannot
have it without without the
participation of everybody